thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a Trippy
wild ride with Stevo we're really going
on a bad trip with this guy I'm telling
you man he's uh pretty into
hallucinogens
drugs it's crazy I'll let him tell you
all about it but I can't believe he's so
open also uh his problems with Johnny
Knoxville really got serious
um that's juicy stuff I mean he's just a
great guy I mean who doesn't love Eric
Andre this is a great episode so let's
get into it
ladies and gentlemen Eric Andre In the
Flesh hey yeah we did one with one of
these with you on uh Zoom yes this is
much better yeah you're uh how much
mileage you got on this [__] uh this
van I just hit 43 000 miles wow we drove
all across the country with it
farthest we've taken this thing uh
Austin
Albuquerque
yeah uh do you have more miles on this
or the the Bertha at the the tour bus
Bertha has more than 60 000 now the tour
bus is when you're filling the condoms
with sewage right that's the tour bus no
no that's this oh this was the sewage
condom well you were there no no I just
saw the footage I just saw it on the 1.5
yeah this one uh is this good is this
good yeah because it's kind of like
going what yeah you know let it go let
it let it do its thing man that's great
okay that works
um okay so like hot off the press Eric
Andre season six six six six six
um was that the first season that you
lost an alarming amount of weight for so
I tried to do a body modification almost
every season so the first two seasons I
just was regular and then the third
season I permed my hair like Katt
Williams and then that got me inspired I
wanted to do like full Christian Bale
body odds nice so season four I started
I was trying to lose a ton of weight
like Joaquin Phoenix and the Joker so I
was just drinking vegetable soup almost
every day
yeah and the Joker when he's skinny as
[__] or like Christian Bale and The
Machinist Jared Leto and the Dallas
Buyers yeah
but I think Jared Leto did it as well a
little bit in that movie I don't think
he was I think so I think they both kind
of went for it but uh so that was a
failed attempt I was trying to do it and
I was so exhausted and the Eric under
show like those guys
are incredible and that what they do
obviously but uh they just have to act
not saying acting is easy but like
I had to write and produce while I was
doing that body of modification and I
was so hungry and miserable
and tired and how long were you doing
that for I was just I just did it like a
couple weeks and I I failed so like as
soon as we started shooting I like
started binging hot cheetah it was like
I was losing my mind I started binging
donuts and Hot Cheetos and stuff like
that so it's season four I tried to get
as gaunt as possible but it was a bit of
a failed attempt and then I was like
season five I wanted to get as fat as I
could nice and uh it was funner fat is
the funnest out of the three but there's
they're skinny fat and buff and the the
fat is the best so season five I just
would eat pizza and peanut butter jelly
sandwiches before bed every night and
bananas and as much sugar as possible
how much weight did you put on I got up
to
I think again at the most 40 45 pounds
um if I did it again I'd do it even
better I would do melted ice cream pina
coladas liquid calories so I really pack
it in I want to do as much carbs and
pizza I would do like liquid
um liquid calories but uh that is fun in
the beginning then you start getting
really depressed and everything starts
kind of aching do you have a
nutritionist to forget fat no I just
like did it like I just asked a couple
actors how they did it and I just like
ate my [__] eight Philly cheese
steaks all the [__] time it was
awesome yeah it's awesome I'm lucky but
but it does prevent the damage to your
body because once your fat cells expand
they know how to expand forever so now I
used to I was always skinny growing up
and I never had to worry about what I
was eating and some of it's with age but
like since then like I can't like just
eat whatever the [__] I want to drink
whatever the [__] I want because the fat
cells now are just like they go back to
that pretty quick are you is that why
you're drinking a lot of water is that a
gallon a day you're drinking
um this is like a bit of a lie I think I
filled it halfway because like
season this this current season we're on
season six
I got jacked and I had to lose all the
way oh also when we wrapped the fat
season
covid started and then I was like
depressed and miserable and I just kept
on the way because I was like just
drinking white Russians in my house all
day yeah so then I was like all right
like I have to
lose the weight for health reasons and
mental health reasons but also I want to
like get ripped so season six it was
like I did a calorie counting app a
gallon of water a day
uh I ate like a ton of protein
um I would work out with a trainer in
the morning for like 90 minutes I would
go for like an hour walk at night just
like super healthy and I got [__] in
shape you really noticed your mental
health changing as your weight went up
and down
I think once you get in the groove at
first you're
not pumped mentally because you're
depriving yourself of your favorite drug
which is sugar
so I think sugar is like one of the most
powerful drugs so you're like going
through like a withdrawal you're like
irritable yeah you're irritable you're
crazy it's on day five no sugar oh
really did you cold turkey it yeah look
that's that's hard man I commend you I
don't have a headache at 3 P.M yeah yeah
be easy I would say what you say to drug
addicts taper taper is tapering is more
successful than cold turkey right I mean
with sugar because sugar and cocaine and
most drugs they all I mean maybe part of
your brain so it was an alcohol but I'm
not sure that I've ever heard people
recommend tapering off of hard drugs no
tape if you don't if you don't taper off
of Xanax you can seizure same with
alcohol and same with alcohol if you're
a real alcoholic and you cold turkey you
can die right I understand in Xanax
detox they tell you taper taper taper
right because you can really [__]
yourself up if you don't tape or if
you're addicted to if you're physically
addicted to it I think rather than taper
off these drugs what they would do is
they would have you under like a a
medical detox and super professional
environment yeah but even in the medical
detox or tapered I mean when my friend
went to do anything when my friend went
into rehab for he's addictive Percocets
he goes day one is the best dick as they
give you all the drugs he goes you don't
quit cold turkey he goes they give you
all the drugs and he goes all the
people's in there was like they're like
hiding the pills in their cheek and [__]
like that and like putting them up their
butt but he goes That's the best day
because you're [__] high as a kite
and then he goes and then slowly but
surely they tape her he goes never
my friends from Florida he's like ex
drug addict [__]
top-notch extra attic and he uh yeah he
was like you gotta [__] taper with
with stuff like Bill with like Xanax and
stuff like that so I think
when I lost the weight the same applied
with sugar where I didn't quit cold
turkey that Noom app really helped me
the calorie counting app yeah and they
were like there's no such thing as bad
food don't give yourself this like
binary thinking of like oh it's good
food and there's bad food and I ate the
bad food so [__] it I [__] up they're
like after where I'm at right yeah you
don't want to do that they go just think
of foods as there's some foods that are
more calorically dense and there's some
foods that are less calorically dense so
stuffed with less caloric density that
had like grapes and celery and and like
watery fruits and vegetables you can
pretty much eat all day you can go
[__] nuts you can eat watermelon
cantaloupe cucumbers celery lettuce
tomatoes anything that's a really watery
fruit has such low
amount of calories and so high in
nutrients your body uses every second of
every bit of it and doesn't turn into
fat
and then there's more calorically dense
foods which they're not like you have to
quit everything that's which is like
chocolate wine cheese candy whatever
that it's not watery and it has a lot of
calories it's hard to burn but nowhere
in their teachings is like cut it out
completely they're just like
moderation not deprivation it's all
about moderation so I would like if I
was losing my mind I was like I just
need a [__] Snickers bar I would take
the stickers bar I would like chop it in
half or chop it in the fourth eat it
satiate that craving and then like go
back to grapes and blueberries and
raspberries and turkey and cottage
cheese and stuff like that that everyone
could eat so so that um
it sounds like I'm lecturing you but I'm
not but but because I went through it it
was it but I'll tell you this after I
wrapped the day I wrapped I got down to
173 pounds I've never been that light
since high school under 10 body fat I
was like nine percent body fat
the day I wrapped I went to Prince
Street Pizza and I ate an entire [__]
pizza and I went to sleep and I woke up
and I went to Russ and Daughters and ate
like three bagels and I went back to
sleep and I slept for an entire weekend
and then I went on a crazy drinking
Bender
like drank like 55 cocktails every day
for like there's a lost there's like a
lost week in my brain for New York and
then I was like wow I'm really I need to
chill out and then I went to Portugal
and drank my Wayne and wine and then I
stepped back on the scale and I like
gained all the weight back that I took
six months to lose was that when you
were because I was being so rigid the
only car sorry the only carbs I was
eating were like Japanese sweet potatoes
and I kind of lost my mind
yeah was that in New York when you met
up with Benny Blanco for dinner
I don't think the last week yeah no I
don't think Ben was Benny there that
week no I don't think Benny was there
that week it was we were absolutely fun
Story We wrapped last year so like
uh all the Prince Street Pizza
debauchery and and
weight fluctuation that happened last
year I'm just back to my normal fluffy
self yeah so yeah
um but you never heard tapering I
thought you'd be like a taper
no cold turkey is the one I thought cold
turkey gets you really sick
unnecessarily well it's like I guess it
depends what's that so it's like we're
extremists so it's like yeah you want
the [__] just go I mean when you go into
detox they they'll give you like a
replacement like Suboxone or something
and then they'll taper you off this box
I wasn't an opiate guy though you ever
had anybody die in The Sober Living when
they're like coming in for like hard
[__] yeah six people have died well no
not for not from the details
I was a cocaine and ketamine and uh
I got sure it took some pills but
yeah I guess cocaine you don't taper
yeah you don't want to taper ketamine I
guess I'd love to taper off cocaine I
think benzos and opiates you have to
taper because yeah the addiction the
physical addiction is different than
those other jokes right the physical
your body really becomes completely
dependent on getting them because
because your body naturally produces
opioids or something right serotonin
some [__] but one thing your body does
not naturally produce is Success if you
want to succeed you got to take action
and the best way to do that these days
is with ship station because man when
you build an audience and you sell stuff
directly to them ship station is the
ultimate tool because whether you're
selling on Etsy eBay Amazon your own
website doesn't matter ship station is
one easy to use interface that brings it
all together along with all of the
different methods shipping FedEx United
States Postal Service ups and they give
you the best rates for those shipping
services that are normally just for like
Fortune 500 companies they give you the
best deals they make it the cheapest to
make it the easiest when you get an
order the label prints out you slap it
on there and that's how I'm selling
Stevo's butthole Destroyer hot sauce and
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole on
Amazon on stevo.com every order man it's
sent out because of ship station and if
you want to get a 60-day risk-free trial
then go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo again success does not happen
without you taking action so go to
shipstation.com use the promo code Stevo
and get into your risk free 60-day trial
man it's crucial so makeshift happen now
let's get back to it
Benny Blanco and man what a riot that
guy is he's like a brother to me dude
he's the greatest he's the best
I feel like he's so uh anxiety free like
just
he has anxieties but he hides him well
but he doesn't fly yeah he's a complete
flight phobia so that's right he made
that clear but he is very he is very
confident and cool calm collector yeah I
thought I I even told him after the I
said I feel like you and Eric Andre are
almost like the complete opposites I
feel like Eric Andre is so gripped by
neuroses
he he maybe I don't know I don't want to
say too much I know he wouldn't really
give a [__] but like his dad was so
crazy growing up that I think he was
like he does everything he can do to not
become his dad okay
he said the the you can do like a
thousand whippets in one sitting more
more probably ten thousand but tanks I
can go through tanks
um and and I asked him did did he ever
feel worried about you maybe going to uh
overboard too overboard with nitrous and
he said oh no no he describes you as um
like a very calculated almost uh if not
moderating your use just very educated
about it um
and you you tell me just a moments ago
that you don't seek to asphyxiate
yourself with nitrous the way I did
I mean I have but uh that's the part
that's bad for your brain nitrous oxide
isn't actually too bad for you but
asphyxiating is very very bad for you so
I try to uh so how many times would you
say you have uh what's called fished out
when you you uh I fish I've fished out
before yeah yeah it feels great I fished
out on mushrooms which is probably my
favorite High wow how does that happen
just ripping nitrous and not getting
oxygen to your brain but on mushrooms
um you eat mushrooms
no I'm sorry fished out on that combo
combo platter oh it's mushrooms and
nitrous fish and a little bit of Xanax
that's my sweet spot
yeah that's my favorite drugs and and a
few I'm growing out of are are booze
Xanax caffeine
nitrous oxide and psilocybin mushrooms
MDMA isn't that bad too do I do MDMA
therapy I do MDMA and psilocybender you
really do therapy with that and I've
done ketamine therapy too but I don't
like it as much as the MDMA therapy now
yeah I've seen that like you go down
yeah there's a road drive down in L.A
that's like sponsored by ketamine
clinics it's like you're on ketamine
clinics Highway yeah and uh we've heard
about different people doing that is
ketamine Clinic like just a lot of fun
is it like you're stoked to go uh I only
did it once
um it was the cleanest ketamine I've
ever done and it's done you know
intramuscularly with the syringe so it
was like a very
it was the most powerful ketamine
experience I've ever had I'm not a
ketamine guy it's a disassociative I I
don't dislike it
it's just not my go-to weed I actively
dislike it's the only drug I dislike
ketamine is is is just it's not for me
but I'm not mad at it and I've done PCP
before and they're they're basically
kissing cousin they're very similar
right um and it's cool and it's
interesting but it's like it's like when
somebody hands you some like
experimental food like this is
rattlesnake Foie gra and then you like
you eat it okay that's interesting not
mad at it but I don't know if I'm
running back to order the rattlesnake
Foie Graw again or whatever the [__] it
is that's how I feel about ketamine I
just go this is interesting I'm having
an interesting thing but it's not it's
not for me and I didn't get as deep in
my
uh emotional catharsis as they did with
MDMA therapy psilocyment therapy what is
what what's the high difference between
Street ketamine and like pure as [__]
ketamine well
it's like the way you ingest it like on
the street you're snorting it yeah and
then in the clinic you're getting it you
know right into the vein so I think
Street ketamine is basically PCP PCP is
it's kind of the same thing it's
dissociative and ketamine is like
pharmaceutical PCP yeah cook in a
microwave PCB started out pharmaceutical
Pharmaceuticals yeah about that yeah I I
love it all yeah I love it all I I just
can't get enough I mean I I absolutely
last time I did an acid I was like I
think I'm done I think I've done enough
acid where I've like explored it and I
think I aged out of it but the first
early acid days were the best and just
you get to a point where with it where
I'm like it's like dirty it glued me to
the floor I was a [__] math lesson I
did it in quarantine and I was a [__]
wreck yeah it wasn't fun I was like oh I
got two hits of the Grateful Dead acid
in my house like the original batch the
sunshine acid that guy made but uh I'm
saving that for a special occasion
Timothy Leary now he's a famous dude I
forget was [__] god it's not Ken
keezy it's not Timothy Leary like the
Grateful Dead had the guy that designed
their sound system made their acid the
wall of oh it's got the wall of powers
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's a famous
guy I'm not a dead I don't really
remember his name but yeah
um
uh yeah but uh yeah I've had tremendous
help with them so you said that the the
ketamine Clinic was the most powerful
ketamine experience you've had so you
really do get high as balls high as a
[__] kite
dude I went to a
h
like and then like
Kirby from Game Boy was like [__]
dancing on clouds in my mind yeah and I
saw like my my neural Pathways like
combined and unfold and I got into it
was [__] crazy it was crazy I
remember being on ketamine just
recreationally and in a hotel room I was
in the bath and like looking at my feet
they were like 30 yards away like your
own depth perception just is just warped
yeah like and then I was sitting there
and uh I was in this hotel room the
whole hotel room just went into Free
Fall whoa and I was like I wasn't scared
I was I even looked up and I I like saw
like a shaft that the hotel room was
falling through that's wild and um I
just thought man this is the coolest
thing ever like I loved it the craziest
heart I ever experienced was the toad
Venom the 5meo DMT that was a [__]
most powerful psychedelican ship and
that was again [__] in Mexico City it
was [__] crazy
I've never experienced a high like this
it's like mushrooms and acid and
everything is over here and it only
lasts like 10 minutes yeah and uh
you you like control alt delete like you
it's a factory reset your entire brand
is like
total darkness just emotion you feel
like you're having like 10 000 orgasms
in the center of the universe you're in
a different dimension you no longer
exist your body doesn't exist this room
doesn't exist Earth doesn't exist you go
through every emotion
uh it's just like raw emotion in like
the 45th parallel [__] The Fifth
Dimension yeah you're on Neptune and
then I came out of it crime I mean this
is an email topic but my dad just died
of cancer so I went there for like on
some like Eat Pray Love kind of chip and
I was like talking directly to my dad
and balling crime the tremendous
emotional catharsis balling crying
worming around on the ground but I came
out of it with like it felt like um
emotionally ejaculating it felt like
this Great Purge of all this tension and
build up and stress from watching my dad
deteriorate into death and uh it really
really really was a cathartic and
therapeutic experience it's not
recreational there's no room for this to
be addictive or recreational you're out
it's like propofol you're like [__]
you're not you're gone yeah you're not
here you know it's not a party drug
there's no room there's no version of it
where it's a party drug it um it was one
of the most crazy psychedelic
experiences I've ever experienced you
did it under the supervision of a shaman
yeah
in Mexico City yeah and this guy was
incredible he's a total sweetheart
what's that [__] they blow up your nose
when you're with the shaman I don't know
I didn't do anything I didn't do any
nose blowing but they just go
they blow stuff up your nose they do
that with tobacco is that what I've seen
that on the Michael Pullen yeah why do
they do that just to kind of enhance the
journey I think there's like a
psychedelic aspect to taking tobacco
that way I really don't know I don't
know
man yeah yeah we had Tyson talking about
the toad last time he was [__] crazy
it is Inc it's completely
uh Like No Other Drug experience I've
ever had and it comes from a toad
but like you're not licking a toad no
you're not licking a toad you're like
smoking the Venom that comes out of it's
like the toad lives in hibernation most
with life it lives in the Sonora Desert
and it's like under under mud like nine
months over the year and it only comes
out for three months to [__] basically
and they're gnarly toes they eat rats
and stuff they're like oh [__]
they're like the Dwayne The Rock Johnson
of toads
and uh
yeah it's venom has a serotonin
derivative and when you smoke it
and it was just some random guy there's
no history behind it there was there was
some book some zoologists wrote a book
on frogs and toads in the 50s or 60s I
don't know if I have the solely right
this is what I heard in the 50s or 60s I
believe some zoologists wrote a book on
frogs and toads and then there was just
one sentence in that book about like the
combustion of the poison of the bufal
various toad creates a serotonin
derivative so some Maniac in the 80s was
like I'm gonna find this toad
smoke the Venom and see if I trip did I
tell you this is a Trippy episode or
what I mean sometimes you gotta try
stuff now I don't need to be trying toad
Venom but I'll tell you I'm very glad
that I tried Bluetooth tablets because
it is very very helpful for my
relationship with Lux I didn't even
think I needed it but turns out I've
wanted it I really really enjoy it Lux
and I super enjoy it and if you think
taking Bluetooth tablets which of course
have the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except they're only a
fraction of the price if you think it's
fun I can assure you that it is I can
also assure you that if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo you could get an entire month's
supply of YouTube tablets completely for
free all you pay is five bucks for
shipping let that sink in it's an entire
month supply of Bluetooth tablets and
you get it for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping now that's an
incredible deal plus it's easy to make
it happen because they got a little
medical provider service on the website
you get the prescription taken care of
like that the Bluetooth tablets are on
their way to you and next you know
you're having a good time like me and
Lux so it's a lot of fun if you're
thinking you might want to try it jump
on it right now bluetooth.com with the
promo code Stevo now let's get back to
it
then this guy went to Saturn's rings wow
so it's not there's no like there's no
like indigenous population there's no
Native American history behind it like
Ayahuasca or mushrooms like Marina or
whatever just some Maniac dude just some
Maniac dude salsa was reading a book
about frogs and toads saw that one of
the most obscure toads poison creates
like a serotonin derivative when you
combust the poison give it give it a
shot that's right and then there's like
uh in the Amazon there's a toad and
they'll take the toad and they put it on
an arrow and then they shoot people
kill you oh [__] maybe I don't think you
saw that on Apocalypto
where you guys keep boiling in here you
want to open the door
what about AC
too loud I mean I I don't know like you
got fans yeah you're not hot it is like
a son in here
you guys are comfortable this is [__]
it's Guantanamo Bayonne
so did you tour with the dead I
found people dead for a summer
because you love their music so much are
you because you're a drug
Enthusiast I just wanted to party yeah
how old were you when you traveled with
them were you getting nice cold fatties
I was 20 years old
it's a fun time yeah I was 20 years old
it was 1994. was Jerry still alive I was
still alive when did he die he died in
95. oh [__] so you caught the real end
of the real deal [__] yep I mean dude
they these Grateful Dead shows were
exclusively in football stadiums which
would hold I want to say like
sixty thousand
Jesus and especially an open drug Market
absolutely not one of those shows uh
like
not one of those stadiums could fit how
many people showed up
yeah yeah that's crazy I mean I think
it's possible that there are even more
people outside the stadium during the
concert than there were inside the
stadium
[Music]
so it was just an open drug Market oh
100 why don't why did the cops not like
raid those whoa I had this one
experience one day because because I
would sell drugs
oh I think I heard this you would do
like a backflip for five bucks then sell
a whip it for 10 bucks
yeah you climbed the the the capitalist
Grateful Dead ladder
I would show up with nothing do a
backflip yeah you know and then like I
would buy like two hits of acid for for
five bucks and sell a beach for five
bucks then I'd buy yeah dude you
basically nailed it amazing yeah but the
cops busted you were well there was one
time and I want to say it was right at
the end I believe it was like metal
lands you know maybe New Jersey
um and uh I was I was selling
I had a bunch of acid on me too at the
time like uh and I think I sold like
maybe like three hits of acid for 15
bucks or something you know and like I
handed the guy the acid and he handed me
the money
and
like out of the corner of mine so I saw
a cop like witness no no
in that moment and then the cop said hey
you know like and I just took off
running dude because I had a bunch of
stuff yeah yeah I took off running and I
think I ran faster than you ever than I
had ever run before and I perfectly got
away
I just outran the cops nice acid back in
the day was such serious jail time like
manslaughter or some [__] they're crazy
it's not still jail time now I don't
think they updated the laws yeah slow to
[__] and that's what the Grateful
Dead was was this kind of like a train
that just ran around leaving people
incarcerated in its wake whoa like they
were just like people I would have been
one of a great many deadheads like
incarcerated for like decades so really
do you think there's still deadheads in
jail I would say so I think so brutal
yeah I think that like to sell acid was
like classed as like attempted murder or
something like [__] [__] yeah
[__] it's it's crazy
um okay so let's talk about the prank
show dude prank panel you Eric Andre
show
I'm a man of many pranks
take your pick brother man okay humble
brag
and brag I uh I saw on your Instagram
that the prosthetic tits what's going on
with those I just had some nice ass milk
jugs uh I interviewed Donald Glover and
I
um they sprayed milk so I offered him
some breast milk
nice and then that was all you did with
them
well I think I like squared it on some
breast milk drank it offered it to him
yeah nice good a long way for a gag you
want me to have my neighbor bang some
pots and pans outside
it is nice and cool now though right
yeah yeah it was on a [__] panic
attack oh man how about that yeah I
[__] melt down in here I never saw
that dude it never even occurred to me
that it was warm yeah but yeah Vinnie
for God's sakes next time we could bring
the stupid air conditioners yes it was
raining so I didn't think we were gonna
need it you never think do you that's
the problem
um okay so uh you worked with Jeff
Tremaine
on season 666 yeah yeah yep and um yeah
and that is the same Jeff Tremaine that
he made the bad Trip movie correct how
did it go working with him on season 666
compared to bad trip well bad trip was
such an enormous undertaking that and I
do want to shout out the director of bad
trip kitao Sakurai my brother from
another mother the love of my life my
work husband who also co-directed season
six of the Oregon show then he got a big
gig and Jeff came in to shoot a bunch of
the prank stuff so
I want to shout out could tell but um uh
season six six six with Jeff was
probably a dream because like Jeff yeah
less pressure exactly Jeff and I went
through it all went through every
emotion on bad trip and bad trip was
such an enormous creative undertaking
and we fought so many battles and
there's so many heartaches and it almost
failed over and over and over and over
again that after going through something
like that that the
you know the little pranks on
the show that I had already been doing
for 10 years was like a dream and a
breeze with with Jeff and and we were
going into it a lot uh older and wiser
yeah
um had you already filmed the prank
panel with Knoxville
uh when you did season 666 no we wrapped
May of last year may 2022 we wrapped
season six and then prank panel we did
in the fall and winter of okay yeah now
add you already done the prank panel and
famously
um
stressed your relationship with
Knoxville
would that have affected your shooting
with Tremaine on uh season 6660 thing no
because uh
I don't think there's anybody that's
been tortured by Knoxville more than
Jeff right Jeff was the one so I did
I've been doing this show with Knoxville
and I know he's gonna prank me
and he's like the liquid Terminator he
started to prank back because he feels
no pain
and then if you do bring him back and he
gets pissed it's like you've unleashed
the [__] monster yeah it's a loose
loose so he keeps like hitting me with
tasers and stuff like that oh my gosh
yeah off the bat
so day three and then like I quit like
the like three days into shooting
because I was like it's only gonna get
worse I don't want to do I was like
I was like it's a nice gig but I it's
not worth the stress I have other gigs
to to keep me afloat
so I called Jeff and I was like and then
I said I quit out of nerves the first
few days
and then Knoxville tucked me back into
it but also Jeff I go Jeff what do I
what do I do like
it's a lose-lose if I if I hit Knoxville
with a prank he's gonna hit back tenfold
and Jeff just goes yeah you got it you
got to hit him back because he's gonna
keep he's gonna keep killing you you
gotta tase him or do something like I
don't know if it was the best advice so
I have like a I have a stun gun next to
my bed
and I had a long sleeve shirt on and
pants at work so I go to set and
Knoxville it's like a Show's like
American Idol or shark tank but for
pranks so people come on and they pitch
pranks to to try to convince us to help
them produce it because they want to
prank their cousin or their wife or
their husband or whatever
so we're interviewing a contest and a
potential contestant
and uh Knoxville's like asking her
questions and I like slowly take this
long looks like a police
yeah take this long thing awkwardly out
of my clothes and I just try to like
nail them right in the chest with it I
was like I gotta make it count because
yeah you know it's gonna be a day so I
like nail him but the guy is like
a James Bond villain he was just getting
electrocuted and then he just like
grabbed it out of my hand and then he
had another weapon in his pocket already
and then he started nailing me with both
thanks and I run and he's got me on the
ground he's just like nailing me with
both um stun guns and this lady is just
standing there like what the [__] he
chasing me out of the studio
and then uh
I was like I'm in a world to her no
that's when I first quit
man I can just feel his anxiety and his
discomfort and it just makes me glad
that this episode is brought to you by
better help because sometimes you gotta
just talk about stuff you gotta process
stuff and better help is the best way to
do that because it's got a whole network
of licensed professional therapists and
they've got this easy system of matching
you up with the perfect therapist for
you and you don't have to worry about
going into anybody's office traveling
across town no because you can talk with
this therapist online at whatever time
is convenient for you and it's easy to
switch it's easy to do everything and
therapy is good for you so
try this out and to get 10 off your
first month with better help go to
betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Stevo go to
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month with better help and man therapy
is where it's at and if you're feeling
like you could benefit from it then jump
on this deal ten percent off at
betterhelp.com Stevo now let's get back
to it
I was like I'm in a world of hell I was
like this is gonna be and Knoxville's
smiling ear to ear because he's like oh
that's great we got footage this is
great that lady was boring and we made
we made and it is great and I totally
understand the value I was not like wait
why why would he want to continue this
type of debauchery I totally yeah I'm a
super fan of Jackass so like I I totally
get it it's only wrong if it doesn't
happen on camera
yes yeah yeah there you go
and uh
so I don't remember the next day oh I
had the props Department rig a little
water gun right by his crotch and
because we sit at this big desk yeah and
I had them cue the water again while
he's interviewing another contestant
it's nailing him in the crotch when he
looks I wanted to stand up and it looked
would look like he peed his pants
but he didn't really react he was like
and he was like go ahead and I could see
him getting like angry I was like oh
[__] like cartoon thermometer like Elmer
Fudd frustrated and I was like [__] and
then I turned to look at the producers
and he stun gun me in the neck and it
was like the most unbelievable pain I
mean you guys have a high pain tolerance
and you not really really I don't think
we do
it just means that our desire for
attention outweighs our desire for
comfort
pain that like went into my brain and it
you're just you can't not be in a bad
mood so then I quit then I quit and I
was like I have to quit permanently
and then uh
uh uh
he called me the next day to apologize
and
I was like uh look I totally get it I
grew up on jackass you guys jackass came
out when at the perfect time for he came
out when I was in 12th grade and it was
the perfect and I remember I had the CKY
tapes and everything it was the perfect
show to grow like be like in those
formative years experiencing and I was
like I love you I love what you do I
completely am not taking it personally I
completely understand the comedic value
but it's just me and Gabourey Sidibe I
know you ain't gonna [__] stun gun or
tase Gabby Sidibe
so you're just gonna attack me and I was
like I can't be your pinkish I can't be
your punching bag for every day day in
and day out every episode every season
at least like jackass like he spreads
the wealth a little bit there's like
nine of you there's a whole Wu-Tang Clan
of you that he can punish right at any
time so and you're all in it together
and there's like it's kind of like
there's like he's spreading the wealth a
little bit he's not just picking on you
or picking on Zach or picking on you
it's a little bit more like you're just
saying I can't be a danger Aaron
no hard feelings I was like I can't come
back I was ignored feeling you can
replace me with Aaron I think I
suggesting I was like you can replace me
with Aaron you can like what no hard
feelings I just can't be in that
position I just don't like the stress is
not worth the gig or the money or
anything I'd rather have my mental
health and work on other projects where
I'm not getting it so he goes I'll do it
I've never done before I'll call the
truce I won't prank you anymore I was
like it's not pranks it's just like
assault with a weapon
I was like I it's not worth the stress
so then we called it truce and I could
tell and I was like as sure if you want
to do that if you want me back on I was
like I don't want you to hold a grudge
or any animosity because I'm taking your
toys away I want you to have your
superpowers I just can't be the one that
you Unleash Your superpowers on and he's
like I hold no grudge no animosity it's
all peace and love so and I never took
it personally I totally got that it was
part of it I was like it's your stick I
understand shtick you got you got a
thing and you figured it out and you you
cracked the system the comedy
entertainment system in your own way and
I just can't be Aaron can't be Aaron
said he was able to so I came back and
we just didn't prank each other all
right he was able to get honor his word
yeah I mean there was a couple of
[__] objects thrown at my crotch or
something like that but no like stun gun
no weapons to the neck kind of thing
right and I even told him at the end I
was like you can fire me between Caesar
I can tell your your powers are on the
Shelf I don't want to like I I still am
like kind of apologizing I'm like I'm so
sorry you can't attack me anymore it's
very like I'm like I have Stockholm
syndrome
imagine like getting tased in the neck
and then apologizing to the person that
tastes you I'm so sorry that because I
understand what it's like to be
um creatively like stifled you know so I
don't want to ever and I told him that
too I was like I don't want to uh neuter
your creative choices I just don't want
to be attacked I was like you're kind of
like Ike Turner right now like talking
Tina Turner back on the stage like come
on baby I'm sorry I punched you in the
face come on back and sing
and and the prank panel was after you
can handle a lot of pain I don't think
it's the attention thing that you said
because I told I asked him if taser
hurts he goes only when you're pressing
the button and I asked him if stun gun
and
he goes the only thing I would never
unleash on somebody's pepper spray he
goes it's just mean he goes That's the
most brutal pain I've ever some of the
most I think because that was worse than
rubber bullets for you though you had
third degree burns for five days like
normally yeah one day in somebody's like
I'm [__] out get me to the hospital
and you were just like ah you're like
editing just like it hurts so bad what
the burn the fire Angel thing yeah
firing into anything yeah um I I
remember your skin looks totally fine
though I don't see any like I've met
burn victims yeah I don't see any it
definitely faded a lot of tattoos
um knock knock shot early on
he uh it was it was really quite averse
to uh
uh
um stun guns and stuff like I remember
there was uh like a hot potato thing
with stun guns and and knocks with this
was not really not Android he was like
he was like hey man we're doing bowls
next week I can't wait for Bulls but I'm
really not into this and getting shocked
business really but then over the years
he became apparently desensitized to
electricity
oh my God his aversion to it went away
yeah I mean I hit him right in the
[__] chest with it and he was just
like he grabbed the electric eel and
didn't even react yeah yeah and those
things do shock they really shock you
yeah big time huh like he just didn't
didn't I remember when we did the
electric Gilbert thinking man like he uh
Isn't So affected by electricity right
when that's why I knew it wasn't a fair
fight I was like oh if he doesn't if if
electricity doesn't hurt him I'm dead
every day I'm walking the set dead man
walking every time I show up to work I
mean the craziest thing that I saw was
like when they when you guys had the
paddles and were those the real paddles
for the hospital or the ghetto
defibrillators were those were real when
they did you guys did that the danger
yeah I can't remember all right I don't
think I was there for that um
the uh okay so so you recently had this
birthday party and birthdays are for you
are like the most important thing it's
like like my lady looks she loves
birthdays you and Lux take birthday is
so serious it's your own customizable uh
holiday yeah and man you customized it
to get pretty loaded this last time yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you got a little bit
to uh sausage too quickly it it looked
like uh the most
intoxicated bachelor party ever
uh
uh I had a couple drinks in me I had a
couple drinks in me yeah all right yeah
that was in New York yeah yeah I got a
little bit of a little bit of yeah a
kind of a concoction
yeah you spend more time in New York
than L.A I just moved back to New York
but I'm trying to be by Coastal by
Coastal biracial bisexual bipolar
I like it um
you know you know you're able to just
get totally loaded like that like
alarmingly loaded upsettingly loaded and
and just back to normal yeah it's kind
of like Jeff Tremaine
like Judgment at a rap party it's just a
monster that should not be allowed to
roam the Earth
but after the wrap party's back to
normal no big deal yeah yeah
I'm not leaving with Jeff Truman no he's
tell he's told me Tails but I have never
played it with him it's a little bit of
a little bit intimidating I might be
aged out of it but I think uh that that
that's it a Legendary game that almost
deserves its own YouTube video yes but I
don't understand how much footage there
is I'm not leaving if you want to tell
the audience what it is it was born at
rap parties okay for like rap parties
meaning like you know you've just
finished filming like a whole season of
Jackass at this point you don't know if
there's gonna be another season of
Jackass right you know or like after a
movie but like after production wraps on
a project something that you really
poured everything into and and uh and
everyone you have a party a rap party
and like the feeling of these rap
parties was always like
okay this is it you know like we
finished the season of Jackass like it's
never gonna happen again right you know
you don't know that there's ever any
future for it so you're living every day
like it's the last yeah yeah we finished
we finished it's a wrap party for the
movie we finished we wrapped up the
jackass movie there's never gonna be
another one this is it like we're done
we're done it's always just this this
feeling of impending doom that that it's
it's over and and like the rap party is
just that last moment of it and so
because you feel like it's just all over
now you don't want to let go right so at
the wrap party you don't want to leave
the wrap party because to walk out of
that rap party he's like this could be
the end it represents like uh like the
surrendering to to the end right and so
you don't want to surrender to the end
so it was just like at the wrap parties
it was like I'm not leaving and and like
it and it was it was like a formal game
with with security at whatever you would
challenge the security to throw you out
DJ Jazzy Jeff style like in Fresh Prince
when Uncle Phil throws DJ Jazzy Jeff out
of the [__] door you're not allowed
to walk out of the wrap party on your
own two feet you can be carried out by
security yeah but but you're not like we
have to and you're not allowed that's
the Only Rule you can't walk out on your
own TV and you can't throw punches you
know you can't like but you can just you
can just you can your job is to resist
yeah to Evanston and and like we would
like we would link arms you know so that
the kids they can't carry out in
multiple
it would be like pretty gnarly standoffs
you know pretty like heavy duty
standoffs sometimes so every single rap
party every single time it was uh it was
a ceremony it was a beautiful wonderful
ceremony I'm shocked that you never
played the game no no and in the last
jackass
I don't think we ever had a wrap party
for Jackass
Foreigner are two totally different
things okay by the time the premiere
rolls around was there a rat party that
got the most out of control
I remember uh one or two
for the for the for the jackass the TV
show
um and then there were only through so
yeah the the wrap party for Jackass the
TV show was probably the the most iconic
classic one like because you guys were
at the most crazy we were at the crazy
this was the wrap party full of piss and
vinegar I was on ecstasy going around
making out with dudes like licking
armpits I had like one of my first cell
phones ever and I then I pulled it out
of my pocket like early on in the rap
party I was like check out my new cell
phone to Tremaine you know I was all
proud of it and he just grabbed on my
hand and threw it as far as he could
like uh
like uh hey yeah that was it was like I
feel like it was at a place called the
Mayan something or other yeah yeah it
was it was classic man it was epic did
you play Harley down what's Harley down
Jeff told me that he used to oh Harley
down yeah he used to like go out with
you guys and like if you saw a row of
Harley motorcycles like in the parking
lot he would jump into them so they
would like Domino here you go Harley
down
oh man like Domino like 10 Harleys in a
row and when like the angry biker dudes
would come out he would try to blame it
on other people
I don't they that sounds even a little
bit mean-spirited for Jeff Tremaine
like you're not maybe not me no that's
uh I I wouldn't I couldn't picture
Tremaine actually doing that he told me
he did it he went to J he told me that
was a
one of the last times he was arrested
one of the first wait wasn't that like
uh written into
um Bad Grandpa there's a big motorcycle
thing at the end they [__] with like a
motorcycle gang yeah but I don't think
they played Harley down no he told me he
went to jail for Harley down he was like
running from the cops and they found him
wow
was that uh when was that I don't know
crazy it wasn't recently the crazy thing
about Jeff Tremaine is he does like
jackass wild boys the dirt and Eric
Andre and then he does American Airlines
the safety announcement I've never seen
the American Airline that's no directed
that oh amazing
widely thing it's unbelievable I love
watching it every time you see Shawna on
there you see everyone oh I didn't see
it I've always said I'm always like
Xanax out on an airplane yeah I mean
it's even crazier with Spike Spike Jones
is like all this like super high art
stuff and does Jack one of my favorite
movies uh three kings is Spike you know
he's one of the actors
yeah sure
um
um so uh what was I gonna say about
oh Jermaine told me one time he was at I
mean maybe this is his tale to tell you
cut it if you want but like he told me
he was at Red Lion Pub with Knoxville
back in the day and Knoxville like
unloaded his bladder on tremaine's back
Jermaine was like talking to somebody at
the bar and then like he's like he feels
like a little warmth on his back that's
like every that's like every bar every
time like uh there were like two things
like lighting lighting people on fire
yeah
yeah sometimes both so like Jeff turns
around and Knoxville just unloads like
at the end of his bladder like just like
and Jeff said he he picked him up and he
like chucked him through the bathroom
door and started like [__] clobbering
him yeah and then they were like people
like well I freaking out he's like no
this is my best friend or whatever and
they went back to the bar and drink yeah
and I heard
Jeff was in Germany with Bam Bam one
time and Bam like peed all over this
like techno Viking on the dance when the
guy didn't even notice he was just gonna
drenched
there are many many games dude like just
hanging on people peeing in their drinks
oh yeah yeah like you could pee on the
guy and that's fun but if you pee in his
drink and then watch him drink it that's
fine
he's drinking he was so butt hurt
everybody's time one time Pete and keep
Dallas drinking like a g can you tell
new how to handle he goes that doesn't
bother me and then there's the the black
eye game
[Music]
yeah yeah it was like uh there were
different variations of black guy gamers
she's like here you give someone a free
shot and they didn't get a chance give
you a black eye and then you return the
favor or the more fun version wet like
when you just hold your fist out and
they run at it and they run at it it's
their job to give themselves a black guy
black guy game is always fun
one time I went to Tiggy bar with
Knoxville and Jeff recently when we
wrapped Eric Andre shows like a rap
party and uh I'm talking to Jeff and I'm
waiting for this [__] bartender
forever and then I just feel like my
foot feels like it's having the worst
allergic reaction and I looked down and
my foot's like engulfed in flames down
down on the ground and like a lighter no
matches and like a bottle of 151 rum
and he goes oh that was an accident
coming down
yeah it's so funny man because there's
very few I imagine if any other like
groups they're they're really have
played these games yeah
you know I'm part of a special tribe
yeah a very special truck
um then now I was parked outside your
house yeah you delay you've lived in
this house for uh for eight years yeah
it's great man thanks man
um and and when I just went up there and
checked it out I saw the sauna the hot
tub there's a nice bath too uh yeah it's
the same outdoor bathtub and I fill it
with ice and dude
should do it more often I've been in New
York for a little bit but yeah I used to
do it all the time what do you call that
the the Jewish Triathlon yeah
I and so you're into that huh yeah what
order did you do it in
uh if I'm really doing the the triathlon
I'll start in the sauna then I'll go in
the ice then I'll do a cold shower then
the ice bath then hot tub then
cold shower than sauna and I have I have
a spout in the sauna that I filled with
cold water and dump it over my head wow
so you'll go into the house for a hot
shower no no there's an outdoor shower
oh okay
yeah I'll get as hot as I can in the
shower and then do cold in the sauna
sorry then do the cold shower then walk
over to the bathtub that's for hygienic
purposes
no no just to go from extreme heat cold
heat cold heat cold and then after the
cold plunge then in the hot tub yep the
jQuery
yeah
do you speak French
wow no not at all I just said cul-de-sac
coup d'etatable
nice yeah that's CAD man I feel like you
you spoke French at one point in your
life nah man took French in high school
or not high school or yeah I did in high
school whatever who cares whenever
somebody calls you a boca boy you go uh
does that is that just your regular
hatred for Boca but you're not really
from book
um yeah and we've we I think we covered
this in the last podcast you're from
England well I grew up in five different
countries so you know take well did you
ever live in Boca or just your pops is
out there I was primarily homeless when
in Boca
um my mom lived in Boca she would kick
me out of the house and I would be
homeless
so you had a brief bocus then but you
wouldn't grow up my mom moved to Boca
um around the time that I went to the
University of Miami and I was kind of
around South Florida and my mom was in
Boca and I was sort of just can you go
to Ringling Ringling School that was in
Sarasota yeah my sister went to New
College like up the street so yeah that
was in Sarasota so you were bobbing
around but you don't claim Boca because
you weren't there that long yeah I never
claimed Boca I kind of drifted through
it a little bit I was I was drifting in
the vicinity of Boca my mom lived there
oh yeah
um yeah it was cool man South Florida
has been like home-based for my family
where did you grow up mostly in England
until you were what age well all four
years of high school I was at the
American School in London okay and I
went to the University of Miami from
there
uh prior to that I lived in in uh
London for uh is most of your childhood
London
yeah formative years you have no accent
whatsoever I went to the American School
in London yeah did your accent ever come
out or did you ever have one when you
were a child never had one you had an
American accent even as a child in
London yep my my family spoke with an
American accent my teachers my fellow
students All-American interesting I was
riding around on a skateboard it's a
cool place to grow up super cool [__]
red yeah I mean I lived in London when I
was nine
had had as much Freedom As Americans
have when they're 16.
so [__] red yeah I cruise wherever
you know I did it all did you see any
like punk shows what years were you
there did you see that it was like the
cloud you're too you're too young for
The Clash of that right concerts I
remember first concert I ever went to
was twisted sister nice I saw that in
like 1980
five
and uh like 13.
maybe it was 86 maybe it was 86. so like
the first wave of like British punk you
were too young you were like a kid
um like the exploited or subhumans I did
go to some punk shows I saw Gorilla
Biscuits uh-huh did you see like the
specials nah it's not Gorilla Biscuits I
saw Bad Brains so sick I saw Bad Brains
in the 80s 90s
the tail end of the 80s or the beginning
of the 90s that's the time to see him um
I saw Rollins band what else said Jeff
told me some story where you and Rollins
were like [__] the same chick and you
didn't know
and then like he just showed up you
showed up the set not knowing he was
gonna he was gonna be there or something
you guys you're stirring his porridge
are we gonna have Rollins on here I
don't think so yeah you can cut that out
but now I'm just talking [__] you can
cut out whatever you want I think they
said the politely passed he's not doing
interviews at this time yeah Rollins
and um you know if if if we were what do
you call it Eskimo brothers
yeah big web
Igloo Bros yeah big what man it's all
good uh how's your love life these days
I'm single and I'm ready to mingle maybe
I'm ready to settle down I've been on
here and go around for quite a bit who
is the lady I met in your house
that is a good friend of mine who's kind
of like my unofficial tenant but she's
just like living there while I live in
New York God yeah she just moved from
Sublette yeah but I'm like a much casual
okay casual term but she um uh
is an amazing musician
and um she just moved from Toronto so
she's trying to get her green card and
keep getting on her feet so does she say
the flesh flute you can bring her down
her and ask her she's got sick of humor
sense of humor than any of us
100 oh you think we're bumping uglies no
no I mean I'm not I mean she's an
attractive lady yeah she's an attractive
lady I'm not trying to put you on blast
but uh but yeah man yeah derived at this
wildly successful incredibly charismatic
attractive young man thank you just
turned 40. maybe we should [__] okay man
you're bi-coastal by Coastal bisexual
bipolar and whatever whatever bicuspid
whatever the [__] I was talking about
curious
The Fast and the Furious the faster
you're still meditating as much as ever
yeah meditate twice a day yeah yeah
never never don't do it I never don't do
it it's like food yeah I really I really
fall apart if I don't exercise Journal
meditating go to therapy I fall apart
pretty [__] quickly unravel yeah I
have anxiety you know I have anxiety
disorder do you take any uh anxiety
medication sometimes like I'll take a
Xanax on the plane right but nothing
like SSRI
no I'm a little bit I have Zoloft on my
shelf and I haven't touched it yet I
tried Lexapro a while ago I swear by
Zoloft dude yeah I have to have it man
if I don't take Zoloft then I waste so
much time in suicidal fantasies oh
really suicide audition yeah and not
like I would have had not like I've ever
been anywhere near
suicide it's just I just wasted oh
that's good that's good then you found
your it's just wasting time in this
morbid dark place I don't I don't need
to waste time in so a lot when I'm
taking it off that does not happen how
many milligrams 100 milligrams a day
how long have you been doing it I've
been on Zola for almost 10 years and it
really works for you a couple times I
stopped taking it I was in uh this you
know did you start taking it when you um
what got sober were you taking it while
you weren't sober no no I I was sober I
got sober in 2008 and it and it was uh
2013 when
um I started addressing uh issues with
sexual acting out and I I went to see a
a therapist who specialized in sex
addiction and this therapist said man I
really think you uh should be on Zoloft
like you know I just get this incredible
life you know like well this uh built up
like you know it's like you're very
anxious I just feel it radiating off you
and I think he takes off and I was like
man I'm a sober guy dude I don't know if
that that's like
so I got on it and I I noticed it really
helped okay yeah I'm totally done to try
it I just wanted to
try you can't do psychedelics when
you're unnecessary so I wanted to do
buffo this year after my Dad's passing I
wanted to try bufo toad I wanted to try
I want to try Ayahuasca I want to try uh
I never know how to pronounce it
ibogaine Evo gain I want to try all
these psychedelic remedies and then I'm
going to try the I mean we're going to
try this is all right the only thing I
worry about is like sexual side effects
like I tried Alexa Pro once and it just
I couldn't come I was with my girlfriend
in quarantine
and I tried Lexapro and we would have
sex and I was like babe I just I can't
come I can't ejaculate in my
psychiatrist is like yeah that's part of
the deal but my friend who's been on
luxury for a while he goes that happens
at first and then your body adjusting
you soon now I come he just had a kid
he's like I definitely got my [__] has
created life so
um I think Zoloft is probably not yes
that that is the thing it never affected
me that much you know not that big of a
deal I think it just varies person to
person
yeah totally and I think like I just
don't want to um
take benzos too often I would never
wanna
the development addiction event so
that's hell on Earth but Zoloft isn't
the same as like us right now so loves
the SSRI yeah yeah you can't take Zoloft
it's almost like Prozac you can't take
it like a Xanax is a tranquilizer
essentially you take it in an immediate
effect it tranquilizes you SSR is you
have to build up in your system and you
don't you don't really take them like a
recreational drug right right yeah it's
not going to work like uh when you take
it you gotta it's like a half-life kind
of a thing and you got to be consistent
with it yeah and it's on a party drug
you're just like slowly it slowly builds
up in you so that your mood is elevated
out of depression and anxiety versus a
Xanax which is just it was basically the
same thing as alcohol yeah it's alcohol
in a pill right so it suppresses your uh
Gaba receptor which is responsible for
anxiety and then why are there blackouts
with Xanax like so so the same Pathways
your grab receptor
and somebody online will be able to say
this a lot more articulate than I am not
a doctor but like your Gaba receptor is
responsible for memory converting
short-term memory to long-term memory
and anxiety just that your brain uses
the same pathway just your brain's
trying to be efficient and they combine
some highways are combined they have
dual function or multiple functions I
like your dick shoots out different
stuff yeah
addictions.com so your Gaba receptor is
responsible for anxiety and it's
responsible for short-term memory
converting to long term so that's why
when you drink you brown out in black
out and when you take Xanax you you
brown it on Blackout because you're
you're tampering with
um the same receptor that's responsible
for memory yeah I just remember watching
a video of this kid he woke up in jail
on like a triple homicide ate a bunch of
Xanax drank beer [__] murdered a lot
of people you don't remember that's a
psychotic person is that like I drank a
bunch of Xanax I've eaten a bunch of
Xanax and drink a bunch of beer and I
didn't go in a [__] murder spree yes
I guess you don't murder people if
you're not a murderer yeah a murderer
murders yeah yeah no it just reduces
your anxiety but alcohol and and benzos
are uh basically the exact same thing
the benzos are like a pill form of
alcohol my MDMA therapist broke it down
my MDMA therapist that's great broke it
down he broke it down that's great yeah
but I just said couldn't sleep on the
Zoloft thing
um started in 2013 and then um
two years later I am like was it was in
a fairly short-lived relationship with
somebody who was uh aggressively opposed
to the idea of uh like that kind of
medication yeah and while in that
relationship I just stopped taking it
cold turkey yeah yeah and when I stopped
taking Zoloft like boom night and day
that the difference was just so Stark
like uh back into this dark Morpher yeah
yeah yeah morbidden things just crappy
miserable Place yeah if it works for you
it works for you if you and then I
started taking it again night and day
that all went away so I've had the
experience like going back and forth and
back and forth and the compulsive
Behavior to subsided
I mean that's kind of like a different
thing like the ruminating thoughts like
you know because it's all related
anxiety depression and obsessive
compulsive thoughts intrusive thoughts
yeah so I don't know like I mean like
Scott said everybody's different you
know I'm not a doctor but God damn my
personal experience I
have to have Zoloft yeah great now you
see yourself being on Zola for the rest
of your life I think that's how it works
yeah yeah some some say that like you
can this is what psychiatrists have told
me they were like you can be on an SSRI
as long as you need it so you can be on
it for three months if you're in a rough
patch you've been on it for three years
you're gonna be on it for 30 years it's
just totally up to it's just my case was
what yeah I just don't even want to test
the waters yeah yeah no that makes sense
yeah yeah yeah dude so uh how is the
um season 666 going it's tearing it just
started yeah I promise nobody has cable
anymore I feel like is it on Hulu I'm
like
in December oh wow so you can download
it you can watch it on YouTube TV you
can watch it on Adult Swim you can watch
it on the adult swim app and then in uh
December 2nd you can watch it on Hulu
okay yeah and when you say download it
it's on iTunes iTunes yes sir iTunes
yeah that's how I watched it last night
um and how's the new host Felipe Esparza
Felipe is great and we had also my
friend Kyle Bostic host co-host a couple
episodes and we had um this character
called the fridge keeper who's kind of
like the Crypt Keeper we had the most in
episode we did a cold episode
nice dude yeah now when you have like a
guest like Lil Nas X on yeah does he go
into it knowing like okay I know what
the show's about or do you guys give him
like a rundown it's the holzberg we
don't tell them anything and I don't
talk to them uh off camera I don't tell
them anything we put them in a a trailer
far far away from the stage they're
completely isolated from everything
that's about to happen so it's the
entire spectrum of people like not even
knowing my name or the name of the show
to like little nazex who's a little bit
more Savvy and knows knows me and knows
the show but I don't tell them I'm about
to you know dump ice cream on his head
or whatever for sure so uh we kind of
have it full proof where it doesn't
matter whether you know it or not once
explosives start going off and
cockroaches start flying out of the
coffee cup you're going to have a
reaction so you're no better than
Knoxville no I'm not better
going at it yeah I
I can't I'm not allowed to touch the
guests and especially when you prank
people on the street you can't touch
them yeah so yeah I definitely can I've
never really attacked somebody with a
stun gun a weapon yeah so you don't
assault people with weapons but you're
assaulting them with ice cream yes yes
ice cream cockroaches you're not
touching them but but yeah but the
roaches are yeah they're the Scorpions
or whatever they are despicable awful
[__] yeah yeah and everything that you
say about Knoxville is a total double
standards 100 yeah 100 of total
hypocrite
he taught me everything I know yeah
I used it on me yeah total [__] ever
good wow I love it I love the way you
operate
um I I love that that I've always been
invited to your birthday party of course
a lifelong invitation as long as you're
on Zoloft you can come back I think uh
I've only made it to to one and that was
the one where you gave these fancy
expensive hair piece wigs to every guess
oh gosh I don't remember that one were
you there for the drug pinata
I don't think yeah yeah
yeah what kind of drugs you have in
there acid and ecstasy yeah wow yeah
genius this year our drug banana Live
Nation did the party this year and they
were like we can't put illicit drugs in
there I was like okay fine I was like
what drugs are legal I go just put
poppers whippets and Newport cigarettes
in the pinata okay now Newports are no
longer legal isn't that right yeah I
think we got in yeah yeah like because
of the Menthol the Menthol yeah yeah
or something yeah is when whip-its are
legal well they're food grade they're
they're for chefs whipped cream Jesus
yeah I needed a dessert Chef she used
them all the time for its intended
purposes it's common and yeah it's crazy
yeah yeah I guess alcohol's legal yep
yeah alcohol and guns are legal yeah
alcohol and guns you can go to Walmart
you can get Oxycontin Xanax Jack Daniels
and all the weapons you want just walk
out think about that that's wild
government doesn't give a [__] about
your safety we have more people in
prison than any other country they don't
give a [__] and we have mass shootings
like no other country has bad shootings
wow that's a purely American phenomenon
school shootings any country that has a
mass shooting they just immediately get
rid of all the guns so the drug laws
aren't based on safety yeah there's
never any guns in the UK when you're
growing up right like it's right
yeah Canada Australia yeah but Chris
Rock has the best joke he goes the
government doesn't want you to use your
drugs the government wants you to use
their drugs
for sure so yeah all right bro was that
too was that too Rage Against the
Machine deaf poetry gym of a [__]
Dismount no
bro I love you too man yeah it's always
a pleasure you kind of look like Zach De
La Roche uh the highest combo I love
that [__] band growing up I just saw
them at Madison Square Garden before he
[__] well he ripped his leg but
before he canceled the tour I saw them
MSG and they're [__] unbelievable
sure and they haven't aged they're
[__] they look exactly the same it's
insane yeah it's insane yeah they're
[__] great yeah I love them all right
bro
everybody yeah do you mean give me
knuckles
give me a sec
yeah dude Eric Andre is a dear friend
and God bless him for everything now
some of you guys might be thinking wait
a second did they put up two podcasts in
the last week you bet your butt we did
and I think we're gonna go ahead and put
up two podcasts this next week
and the week after that why because man
we're on fire for it we love the Wild
Ride we're bringing you content like
crazy baby and those of you who stick
around to the very end are my favorite
people in the whole wide world so thank
you I love you and I want you to have
the greatest day ever yeah